there is no denying that Jessica Simpson
is gearing up for baby number three and
only our Brooke Anderson was with the
proud mama was also having to deal with
some very curious children the kids are
so excited they asked me all the
craziest questions that I can't say on
TV you know I think I'm a little bit too
honest and Eric's like I don't think we
need to give out all the information
that's okay Jess is kind of like our
spirit animal unfiltered and she always
tells it like it is what are your other
pregnancy hacks or shortcuts or secrets
I go with the waddle
you know like immediately when I found
out I was pregnant it's like stick the
stomach out pop the hips out and just
just waddle just own the waddle that is
my struct even with baby number three on
the way the 38 year old isn't slowing
down
she's expanded her 1 billion dollar
fashion empire the Jessica Simpson
Collection into beauty and fragrance
which she calls fiend you know being a
southern girl I love my makeup I am all
about helping others feel their best
I know I know those down days and
sometimes we just you know needle fall
slacker you neither laughing together
yelling
[Music]
Jessa's very hands-on but the one person
who gets final say is her six-year-old
Maxwell drew she's very strong in her
opinion the other day actually I was
trying to make her wear this Gucci
jacket that I bought her and she's like
ah no Gucci and I was like what you
can't say that Jessica's mini-me is
excited for her baby sister on the way
no doubt they'll love playing dress-up
and we helped get the wardrobe started
with this oh that's so sweet
that's so cute I mean I feel like she's
this size right now she's a lot of fun
well she also told us that one of the
ways that she's trying to be healthy
this pregnancy is getting her steps down
that she tries to get in 10,000 steps
four times a week whoo in those platform
meals I don't know how she's doing it
[Music]